ليله تجلب انظار العالم كله الى الرياض
ميسي ورونالدو وجها لوجهه على ستاد الملك
فهد المره جديده وربما تكون اخيرا رونالدو
بقميص نجوم النصر والهلال وميسي بقميص
باريس سان جيرمان مع مجموعه من نجوم
النادي الفرنسي سيكونون حاضرين هذه المره
في قلب السعوديه المباراه المرتقبه اصبحت
حديث الصحافه العالميه حيث تعد بالكثير
خصوصا وانه اخر لقاء جماعه بين ميسي
ورونالدو كان قبل عامين في دوري ابطال
اوروبا يكون اللقاء المقبل مواجهه جديده
بين نجمين طال ما امتاعه العالم واختبار
حقيقي لنجوم الرياضه السعوديه امام فريق
قوي مثل باريس سان جيرمان سننتقل لكم
اجواء ما قبل المباراه اولا عزمينا محمد
الخامس في الرياض
[موسيقى]
تتجه انظار العالم للعاصمه السعوديه
الرياض وبالتحديد الى دره الملاعب استاد
الملك فهد الدولي حيث الحدث الاضخم مباراه
فريق موسم الرياض امام باريس سان جيرمان
مواجهه جديده تجمع بين الصورتين كره القدم
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو والارجنتيني
ليونيل ميسي مواجهه على ارض السعوديه بعد
ما اعتاد التنافس وجها لوجه على مداري عقد
من الزمن
[موسيقى]
الشعور جدا جميل لما تشوف اللعيبه اول وهم
صغار نشوفهم التليفزيون
عندنا في السعوديه وتتابعهم في الملعب هذا
الشعور يعني ااا
حلو جميل
وتشاهد افضل لعيبه في العالم يلعبون رياض
ااه همم برده في همم منافسه بين كريستيانو
وميسي تتشاهدهم قدامك فهذا شيء الصراحه
جدا عظيم وشكرون عليه والله لمن تتوقعن
انا يمكن عشان يميل لكرستيانو توقع ان شاء
الله هذه فريق موسم الرياض تتكلم عن افضل
اللاعبين نيمار ميسي كريستيانو المباراه
باريس سان جيرمان وفريق موسم الرياض هل
بيكون لها صدع كبير في العالم الناس كلها
بتتابع المباراه كيف يكون صداها يعني
اكيد اكيد بيكون صداعها يعني كبير جدا
للناس العالم المحترفين كلهم موجودين
كرستيانو نيمار ميسي يعني يتكلم عن النجوم
اساطير وكل المتواجدين
طبعا انا دخلت الموقع عشان احجز التذكره
يعني
التذاكر نزلت 6:10 دقائق الساعه 7:20
انتهت فهذا اكبر دليل يعني ما يحتاج ان
همم تذاكر اذا خلص دائما في اي مباراه
خلصت الذاكره في اقل من ساعه عرفت ان
الصدى يعني همم الشعور جميل جدا وشعور
جميله ايضا همم بمناسبه قدومهم عندنا
اللعيبه العالميين
وهذا الشيء يعني همم يزيدنا محبه في
الكوره
والتطور الكره القدم عندك المباراه هسه
تشهد عوده المنافسه مجددا بين اسطورتين
كره القدم رونالدو
صباح العربيه محمد خالد الرياض
رونالدو وميسي في لقاء جديد ربما يكون
الاخير ولكن هذه المره بنكهه عربيه وعلى
ارض الرياض سيكون الموعد المباراه وديه
لكن تابع المنافسه لم يكون غائبا بين
اللاعبي الفريقين لا سيما نجم الكره
العالميه لاخر عشرين عاما ميسي ورونالدو
خصوصا انها فرصه ربما تكون اخيرا لقاء
حاصل بينهما بعد رحيل الدون عن اوروبا صوب
الدوري السعودي ورغم تفوق ميسي بعدد
الكرات الذهبيه التي حققها خلال مسيرته
الا ان الدون خرجوا من اوروبا تركه ورائهم
ميسي في صداره هدافي دوري الابطال
اللقاء ايضا سيكون فرصه ثانيه لتحسين سجل
الدهون امام ميسي حيث توجهها قبل ذلك من
ست سنوات
حقق فيها ميسي 16 انتصارا مقابل احد عشر
ليرونالدو و9 تعادلات كذلك كان رونالدو
يسعى في مواجهته الجديده مع ميسي معدلاته
في عدد الاهداف المسجله في المواجهات
بينهما حيث سجلها ميسي 22 هدفا مقابل 21
هدف لرونالدو
[موسيقى]
العالميه الجميله في قسم الرياضه ليليان
سنوري ليليان اهلا بك قبل ما احكي على
اللقاء التاريخي وبدي احكي على الحضور
التاريخي لك مع نفسك
شكرا
[ضحك]
رونالدو وباريس سان جيرمان الفريق العالمي
حدثنا اكثر عن فكره
صحيح او شيء بدي اقول صباح الخير
للمشاهدين اللي بيشوفوني يمكن اول مره ههه
صراحه هي فكره من اول ما همم
كانت دحشه كبيره لانه همم هذا الفريق اللي
همم
النصر والهلال مقابل فريق باريس سان
جيرمان هي فكره يعني عظيمه وخلاقه وكما
عوادنا همم الشيخ دائما بيقول ما هو جديد
يعني كلمه فوق الخيال عوضنا قالها مره
وكررها اكثر من مره وهي بالفعل فوق الخيال
ليله الاساطير يعني شوفي فينا نحكي عنا
انه همم اذا تكلمنا عن النجوم بهذه
المباراه نجوم شاركوا معظمهم ب- اا نهائي
كاس العالم يعني همم اغلى همم لاعبين
بالعالم اكثر لاعبين حصلوا على الكره
الذهبيه 11 بما بينهم همم يعني كل الارقام
تدل على ان هذه المباراه ستكون همم
اسطوريه بالفعل هي بالفعل الاساطير يعني
متوقع ان يشاهد هذه المباراه اذا كان
نهائي كاس العالم همم تبع هلا فيفا اخر
اصدار لها اكثر من مليار ونصف حول العالم
هذه المباراه من المتوقع ان تتغلب كثيرا
على همم نهائي كاس العالم الاخيره
بالاضافه الى انه لقاء كبير يعني وجود
نجوم سعوديين كبار نجوم عالميين هي مباراه
تاريخيه لانها اول مباراه واول مواجهه
ميسي ورونالدو خارج اوروبا يعني ميسي ثاني
اكثر لاعب واجهه رونالدو ب 36 مباراه فاز
ب 16 مقابل 11 لرونالدو اليوم الى اما ده
ستكون المواجهه ليست فقط استعرضيه بين
ميسي ورونالدو لمن ستميل الكافه في هذه
المواجهات على الرياض
يعني
اي فريق
كل الاجواء بهذه المباراه
ميسي هناك نجوم كبار همم
رونالدو بالتحديد هو شخص تنافس فمن انا
متوقع ان تكون هذه هي يعني منافسه كبيره
خاصه رونالدو انتقل من اوروبا الى
السعوديه فهنا يريد ان يقوم بمجهود اضافه
حتى يثبت انه همم كما يعني توقع جميع انه
هذه ستكون فقط من اجل المال انتقل الى
السعوديه ولكن يريد ان يثبت انه لا هو ما
زال ينافس وما زال قادرا على منافسه وما
زال همم يريد الفوز بهذه المباراه
بالتحديد لانه اذا راينا مواجهات يعني غير
عن همم نيمار وغير عن نيمار همم ميسي
دائما همم رونالدو بيحب التسجيل يعني
باريس سان جيرمان دائما يعني عبر التاريخ
يعني توجهها همم اربع مرات بي همم دوري
ابطال اوروبا كان الفوز الثلاث مرات لي
همم يعني له فريق معه رونالدو على
كريستيانو
ههه دوله الاوساط الاعلاميه الرياضيه كل
مره رونالدو بيسال مين الاعظم انا او ميسي
عشان هي كل مره مواجهه بينهم اهتمامه
وشخصيا واهتمام الجماهير طيب ليليانه مثل
ما قلت نجوم كبار في نادي الهلال نادي
النصر معهم كريستيانو في مقابل نجوم
عالميين في باريس سان جيرمان مبابي نيمار
كريم مثل ما قلتي ونجوم غيرهم
توقعاتك نتيجه المباراه
هو صراحه هذا السؤال
وصعب ان واحد يجاوب عليه ولكن احنا بنفضل
انه نشوف مباراه استعراضيه كبيره يعني كما
يقول دائما المراقبون الان يعني انطلاق
الفكره حتى الان
يريدون ان يعطي كل لاعب افضل ما لديه يعني
احنا نعرف انه اكثر فريقين متنافسين
بالسعوديهم الهلال والنصر يعني ان يتواجد
لاعبون من الفريقين بنفس الطريقه وجماهير
تشجع فريق واحد فريق لقيتها ليس يعني
منتخب سوريا
فيفا ههه مرحبا اولى شكرا ليني اتمنى
حضورك دوم نكون معانا نورتينا اليوم منوره
بوجودك ميرسي شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لك شكرا